every student every family has a
different way of succeeding we want to
provide them as many choices as possible
every parent in Milwaukee in Wisconsin
and across America should have the same
choices that your parents the governor
of the great state of Wisconsin Scott
Walker when you think of choice
offerings for parents and for students
and for families Milwaukee should be
proud to have some of the best choices
out there first and foremost we want to
improve traditional public neighborhood
schools but in cases where there is an
improvement we want to give those
families the opportunity to provide an
alternative it isn't about replacing one
type of school with another it's about
saying we want ultimately want every
student in this community and ultimately
every student has stated to have access
to great education one of the best ways
we can do that is giving them as many
good positive choices as possible I
think that's something that transcends
party lines it transcends ideological
beliefs I think that's a commonly felt
belief and I think representation you
have here today of many different
elected and appointed officials is a
good sign of it I do not want to see the
funding for the public education system
in the state decrease because of the
funding
that doesn't mean I don't support having
adequate funding for each other skaters
and part of the reason I'm here also is
is to have the dialogue and to let
people know that I have to make sure
that whatever system we have provides
for adequate and equitable funding it's
also an economic imperative it's really
really important that you all and every
other kid in the city and in this
community in the state get a great
education have access to education let's
count Governor Walker down as he rings
the bell from five four three
you